[Music]
action
would you like to do the intro
hey that's pretty good good it's still
good yeah so welcome back to
ask the expert espert espert
and uh we have anthony lee here from the
kinjaz
professional dancer oh whoa
put that away bro there's moms in the
room innovation comes at a cost
true that's the tantric sex expert than
you're doing yeah
he creates wet [ __ ] when he wants
walks into a room not in this room
oh yeah dry as a desert hard dips so
what
okay hard dicks though we all got kind
of hard yeah because that was like yo
can i put my dick inside that
that was fast you want to put your dick
into everything
i mean it looks kind of nice so let me
see let's see what joe saw no not you
i want the expert to do it he's all can
i put my dick inside this
oh yeah if i had a dick i don't want to
put it in there
oh
what is happening that's so funny but
anyway so
you guys asked a whole bunch of
questions you were curious to know about
anthony's
dance life and his dance life his
professional dance life
and so i'm going to ask you a couple
questions i'm sorry
whoa are you having a seizure i don't
know i just i was like you guys are
professional dance livestream
you don't look as cool when you do it
this one got his mouth closed though
[Laughter]
no it's like this that's like that it's
a phantom dick
to show you that it's moved that it's
like a live thing
it's a phantom dick that's why your
mouth is closed
there's a lollipop
let's don't do it like this though
flying [ __ ] you that's why i don't give
a flying [ __ ]
this sounds funny dude
you're flying [ __ ] is that right
it's the ugliest middle finger in the
world
all right so first question that i have
here it says or ed
asks um have you ever thought to stop
dancing and why
did you ever consider quitting oh man
like my feet don't work no more
i i've definitely definitely definitely
considered stopping dancing as a career
but not dancing for fun you can't ever
stop dancing because when you hear the
beat your body's like
yeah you can't help it absolutely yeah i
don't think it's ever going to be
possible for me to stop dancing
but to choose to not do it as a career
is definitely a thought that's come to
my mind
from dancer to dancer um i have to say
like
that it's almost like asking somebody
do you want your soul to leave your body
this guy's a real dancer he knows yeah
look at him he's a real deal when did
you when did you have the thought
crossed the mind of like not doing it
for a living
and why or not when but like what made
it
what made you i feel like maybe the
first time was maybe when i turned like
30
and then suddenly you start like that
like invisible switch in your head it's
kind of like are you
you're like not a kid anymore yeah um
and then especially with the dancer
um right we're like not just artists
we're not just like athletes
we're kind of both so it really kind of
depends on how you take care of yourself
but there is a shelf life
to um your prime mm-hmm
what do you mean prime like energy um i
think physicality
you know i think as i gain does your
body hurt it does it's it's harder to
recover
well i have to exercise more so i take
care i take better care of myself now
than i did when i was younger i
stretch more i work out more i eat
better all that stuff
um so i can maintain but when i was
younger
i was throwing my body all over the
place i was like drinking late at night
you know and partying and stuff
damn you old son thank you thank you and
i wasn't really like stretching or doing
rehabilitation as much but it was fine
because i was just younger my body was
just
capable um so just i think once you get
into
accepting a little bit of that
physicality element
i can still mature my creativity and my
ability to like
make stuff or produce uh or direct
things but
kind of being the forefront the actual
mover um
definitely kind of gets checked the the
older you know some advice i have for
you as a dancer please
um i would say that
to avoid that feeling of getting old get
younger
is while you're young be weak as [ __ ]
and then when you're old you'll be the
strongest you've ever been
and healthy so then when you're you look
back and you go i actually feel way
better because you never met your full
potential in your 20s that's smart
so everyone out there do not meet your
full physical potential stop right now
you're young this guy's the limit for me
that's what i'm saying it's only up from
here
you're gonna be like yo 40 like i'm the
healthiest i've ever been
the strongest i've ever been and then
you're gonna look back into your 20s and
be like
that weak ass [ __ ] start slow you just
gotta get fat in your 20s you know
set the bar real low yeah not even have
a bar don't even accomplish anything
yeah yep yeah fail twice even
don't even get back up just fail
don't even just stop yeah don't even try
fail the whole time
that's the best yeah and then you
finally try something
and then it's only up from there yeah
yeah
yeah i'll try that in the next life i
won't try that don't try it
don't try until later got it yeah yeah
yeah okay now you got it
master the art student all right uh next
question is
when did you realize that dancing could
be your full time and did your
parents believe in your dream hell no
to the parents part um do they do they
believe in it now
oh yeah imagine they're still like [ __ ]
no this is a phase it's never going to
be nothing
once you start giving them like you know
cash envelopes and [ __ ] like that it's
like
what is this cash money what you doing
cool at home
your dad talks no my mom though
for me she approaches you sometimes
she's like you want to buy me a car
[ __ ] like that how cute but she'll stay
in vietnamese so it's like
cute and worse anyways um
uh what was the first half that question
before i started my parents
when did you realize that you could do
dancing full-time full-time
if you're curious of that answer you can
check out the previous video he said
when he
was fired from his restaurant job
because he was having
so much work doing other things and then
his boss dancing things why are you a
waiter here when you don't even come to
work
[ __ ] up but i love you i got to get your
shift to somebody else
and he's like okay give it to my friends
cause i got trav
i got traveling to do i get 20 bucks a
session bye
so yeah different kind of paraphrasing
but yes yes so i guess you can focus
more on the second part of the question
which is did your parents be living your
dream
i'm a boy scout by
chopping up timelines
i didn't i didn't reach eagle for
nothing fool and your shopping shop
sucks all right bye
[Laughter]
man there are definitely some like good
fans out there that fully understood
every part of that
i appreciate it for sure that's tight
about them i think uh
there was definitely i'll never forget a
period of time i believe it was a year
and a half
uh that my mom just had the hardest time
accepting and every single time i either
came home or gone on the phone
she would always be trying to be are you
still dancing you should like try and
get another job
or she would try to like set me up she's
like hey uh like i could talk
talk to my friend maybe they can hire
you and it's like mom don't even really
have like
a bunch of like business like uh acumen
so like i was already kind of like
you know and younger just like please
mom stop stop bringing that up and it
actually caused uh separation a little
bit in our relationship
to the point where my dad would even
tell my mom's like why do you think he
doesn't come home
you know what i mean every single time
you're annoying yeah you keep
complaining
shut up like that almost shut up about
his [ __ ] and my [ __ ]
we don't want to head no more shut up
shut up
what do you think was the catalyst to
like accepting it it was
uh it was the i was dancing on a group
called
uh the lxd the legion of extraordinary
dances john m true brought that together
for a couple projects um
and i was there uh in one of their
earlier seasons and then they got a
performance opportunity on dancing with
the stars it was on nbc's dancing with
stars
macy's like uh all-star hall of fame
type thing or whatever where they bring
in a special
kind of performance group so lxd got a
chance to come in
um i was part of this group called the
umbras where you didn't even see any of
our faces were there for like three
seconds with umbrellas doing stuff you
really didn't even see it but
this was a live tv spot when they saw it
on tv that's when they were like
oh yeah so i was like mom you gotta
watch this on tv and the ironic thing
is one our group hella messes up but um
two
she didn't really see me we all supposed
to look like she's like which one are
you is it over i was like yeah it's over
you didn't see
it did you tape it no she watched it but
like it's it's still hard
even for me i don't even know which one
i am sometimes you know what i'm saying
it's just like so fast but
the fact that i was able to even tell
her and then
and then she was like she called her
sister too she's like she's like hey
turn on the channel you got to watch the
tea and it just became this thing that
sometimes you could become proud of if
it's tv or newspaper
yeah that's when they know you made it
but the thing that sealed the deal was
because every sunday my family still
goes out to like boy scout meeting and
stuff right so there's all the parents
because my dad and my sister run the
truth oh hell yeah so once all the
parents are there and all the kids and
suddenly the kids started seeing me on
social media
so the kids knew that i was part of the
troops so then suddenly they'd be like
oh is anthony coming they'd be like why
is
why are you asking my auntie oh because
he's just a you know a dancer and blah
blah
so suddenly my mom was you know kind of
like
you want to see my son like you know
what i'm saying
and uh i'm talking [ __ ] but i love my
mom um you gotta talk [ __ ] though
i think that especially for like an
asian parent that's the thing that
really changes it when her social circle
true is proud of the kid
yeah that's when she's got to be proud
of the kid and if not like 10x proud you
know so
suddenly tv suddenly next thing you know
she's like hey come out to the meeting
i'm like why do you want me to
concentrate so cut out to the meeting
it's all like coming out to the boy
scout me and somebody she's like oh
hi praising me around and [ __ ] like that
like oh you remember my son
you know um but i also felt really clout
chasing dude
um that also for me too was uh just you
know it was finally cool too
it's a proud moment man yeah to be
validated and recognized by my parents
and after that it was
uphill i wish that um i can
unders you know how like asian parents
don't operate off of logic
so like they kind of like it's almost
like dealing with a child
because their brain is like stopped in a
certain
point and they can't they they can't
listen to reason or evidence they just
have to mature for the asian american
experience right
mainly because like their lifestyle is
way different from anything that we're
experiencing we're experiencing it for
the first time they have no
real like relatability to it yeah you
know what i'm saying
for anybody who's like first gen but um
same thing for
nextgen like your kids aren't going to
deal with it
but you know what they will deal with
what probably deal with the
the their father who's like well you
know how i had it
because our parents were you know coming
from like vietnam and china and stuff
like that so like we were raised
different we were raised more stricter
we didn't have this opportunity
so i think that cycle kind of continues
until we're maybe like third fourth
generation here
you know how long i had to [ __ ] wait
for the pictures to load you little [ __ ]
i mean right we all have it in a
different way you know i mean i'm
i'm thinking about like the people that
are like prison like for their whole
lives and they come out and suddenly
there's like cars everywhere in internet
you know what i'm saying like that that
[ __ ] must [ __ ] you up but where's your
page you're at
huh right but yeah i i just think the
asian american experience when you're
first gen is like a unique one and we're
still
like figuring out that story yeah that's
cool
yeah all right next question
which exercises are good for dancers can
you give some tips on how to memorize
all the stan
dance steps oh kegels are pretty good
right kegels is the thing with the
freaking hips right
um i think that uh for me
straight up this is gonna be funny when
people ask me like what were my first
things that attributed to like my desire
for like choreography and dance
it was a martial arts i was in peculiar
as a kid so like learning like forms and
punches and stuff like
it's the first time you're kind of
learning choreo yeah right just like
doing the moves and like being in sync
with people next to your
you know your your masters and stuff
like that that was a huge
kind of um or cool intro for a guy like
me to be like oh
i want to move like everybody or i want
to move well with the technique
did you like flare up those moves were
you like a little bit better than
everyone else
i don't know if i was better i mean yeah
he was like
i was really good at the moves but i
would still get my ass kicked if that
helps
that makes sense cool thank you for it
making sense anyways the choreo versus
the fighters
um we we dance our issues away so we
don't
use aggression you know um but uh
and video games i i think video games
helped with the idea of like
timing and precision right whether
you're like aiming or paying attention i
feel like video games as a kid
plus martial arts was what like kind of
attributed to my
um i guess hand eye coordination
and body awareness i would say that
those are the kind of the the things
that came into it
but in terms of like exercise um
right now like my i think i i
i've tried to do a lot of like um i
wasn't successful but i think when i
went into
thinking like oh let me do some like
weight training or whatever there'd be
times where i might spike in workouts
and then like slow down and movement or
flexibility
and it wasn't until i started like only
doing a lot of like either like
plyometrics or like body weight
and plus like stretching flexibility
mobility and yoga
that suddenly i was like oh this is
actually improving my quality of
movement
and my uh how good it feels
to move i think mobility exercises were
very helpful for me
so that was that i think that
complements my style of dancing though
other people will require different
exercises depending on what they do
you know you might want to train to be
stronger if you're using more
physicality in your movement
you may want to be lighter if you're
maybe focusing on like footwork or like
house or something like that there's a
balance to it so
if i want to be a good twerker i heard
squats are really good to
increase my ass i think that that's very
true i think that you're
that's a very astute observation thank
you yeah
i think you have a nice ass thank you
energy about you
[Laughter]
hey guys today's video is brought to you
by upstart
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off all of your personal debt
and you can qualify online and one of my
favorite parts about upstart
is that you can get approved the same
day
and then get your money the next
business day which is crazy because if
you guys have
ever been in a rut sometimes you need
money you
owe rent you're about to get kicked out
of your house or the repo guys coming to
take your car
and it could not even be your fault it's
just the money isn't timed in well you
know like your income or
or this building cycles all messed up
you can get
out of a shitty situation real fast
i got i got approved for like ten
thousand dollars yeah because i wanted
to see
you know crypto markets doing great and
all so
why don't i just get a loan and i do not
recommend for people to do this i am a
degenerate yeah but i was like
if i wanted to do this could i
and i it worked like in five minutes
they approved me and they're just like
you want to sign up or whatever
and i was like nah i don't want to
gamble with this money
so i didn't do it but if i was in a
tight spot
and i owed a lot of credit card bills or
whatever
this would be a great way for me to kind
of bring it all together under one
apr which was a pretty competitive rate
and i was like dude this is way better
than having like a 20
apr on your credit card so like if you
want to
consolidate everything and do one easy
payment
upstart is the way to go yeah find out
how upstart can help lower your monthly
payments
by going to upstart.com off the record
that's upstart.com off the record don't
forget to use our
url so they know that we sent you baby
loan amounts will be based on your
credit income and certain other
information that is provided in your
loan application
go to upstart.com off the record
babies all right next question here is
how do professional dancers make money
what's in
they suck only fans this one says
and what is a reasonable average amount
of money professional dancers make if
they're independent
versus permanent onset type of
choreographers that work
with one big name star oh they know the
x
they know the language they're talking
almost like it sounds like day rates
almost because they're not talking about
choreo they're talking about like okay
you dance
for like justin bieber and you tour with
them almost it sounds like
versus what's like uh like almost like a
session musician
hey i need a i need a guy that stands
over there during this
choreo is there a statistics on like
this kind of freelance industry of how
much people make because can't you make
like
[ __ ] tons you can't it really depends on
who you are and i think the scale
is like really really wide nowadays
right because um
is there like a dancers union like zach
there is dancer's alliance yeah
um but it's it's still so hard and the
scale is like way off because like a lot
of like dancers nowadays are
utilizing their opportunity by way of
like social influence in the amount of
followers they have
so like again a maybe and just a
hypothetical nobody in mind but like for
example if you have like um
a really popular person who maybe is
like not super skilled to dance their
rate is still going to be higher
than somebody because they bring in eyes
yeah yeah and doesn't have a lot of
followers or something like that so it
depends on the industry that you're
asking if you're booking that person for
like
a musical theater or broadway show
though then you can give a [ __ ] about
the social influence
and you're going to focus on the skill
and make sure they have the skill set to
do
or bring to life the vision of like the
director or whatever um so
i think the rate is really really
dependent
on just the the area of the industry and
then like what you actually bring to the
table
um but in terms of a scale i don't think
that it's
uh you're hiring like the dance
i think dance is like the vehicle you're
kind of like hiring the person so it
depends on what you're hiring the person
for because the dance can
change or be flipped or like you change
the song the dance changes
you change the um the time frame uh
or how long you want somebody to dance
or create for the artistry changes it's
not like you would get this
and then you add on you just get a
little bit more that changes the whole
number
so i think the scaling of it just really
depends on like
the type of craft and then again there
are variables that change that too like
your social influence or like what they
want you for it
aka i'm not giving you any answers
indeed [ __ ] yeah you nosey don't be
asking people how much they make
yes i tell you if it was one number
it's easier i yeah i would say there was
a time though that remember
like in the last video i would say i was
i was teaching class for like 20 30
bucks and i was like
that's easier yeah um but at the same
time now like i'm not going to teach a
class unless you give me four digits for
it you know what i mean because oh
[ __ ] but that's not just because like i
think i hella deserve that
it's because i focus my dance on so many
other things that if i want to go into
if you want me to teach you want to take
away from the other things
the opportunity cost i should well and
it's also
the latter of what you just said because
you've you've
like honed in on their craft and you've
worked on it and you've built it up and
you've built up your name like it's all
of that
yeah yeah it is it's like those memes
that you see right it's like when you
when you hire like a lawyer or something
for like an hour they charge you like
500 bucks they're not charging you for
the hour they're charging you for like
their education and their their
experience
and their parents yelling at them the
whole time until they become a lawyer
and their parents yelling at them that's
what they're trying to do
they have to pay for it i charge like
four g's to teach dance too
and you deserve it we haven't gotten any
gigs yet but
that's right and you also deserve that i
got a free class one time and i walked
out
you walked out yeah because bart didn't
teach torque skills
from bart yeah but he's done hella
squats he was only he's got the biggest
booty here he really does
i know but he didn't drop it like it's
hot
[Laughter]
he's all heartbroken i'm here [ __ ] you
gf
yeah we also learned boogaloo at a boat
shop i know that was fun
yeah what's his name it's a dancer
he's from machine gun funk yeah like
machine gun
he looks native american uh he looks
like uh
taboo from black eyed peas he looks like
him
[ __ ] what's his name oh chad was in that
crew right
not jay smooth um
jason kidd boogie kid boogie kid boogie
yeah
oh my god he just said he look like
he does though that was funny
you know what's funny is that people
think they're old schoolers but they're
not
old i mean they're not oh geez they
learn from the ogs
but they're at this point second
generation at this point i would say kid
builds og and at this point i'd say kit
boogie is one of the
a few ogs that's getting better as hell
he's one of the few dudes he's getting
older and he's getting better it's
crazy how old is he i don't actually
know but he's probably in his he's
probably
like 40 or something like that now he's
probably a little older than us when he
taught us and we were like
in college at the time he's [ __ ] fast
he's like yeah i'm gonna work at this
bubble shop come down and we went
it was in little tote i mean uh little
osaka like he's like he's like teaching
us boogaloo and someone's like oh i get
a milk tea i hold that we put this apron
back on
all right next question anthony is
what were the challenges and steps to
opening up brick and mortar businesses
and what is the next step for kenja's
after closing the dojo and complex
that's a real fan they know your stats
what's up dude
[Music]
yeah oh man that's
that's thick because that's like really
really right now type stuff
so um what about like the first place
you know like i think for
the monterey park place yeah yeah going
from from a concept and just an
idea of this is our crew we can have a
business model to
securing an actual brick and mortar
that's
huge you know yeah i mean i think first
and foremost the first dojo that was in
monterey park
um that was by the way that was uh
crowdfunded
by our global dance community that's
dough wow yeah right after we you know
got second place
um uh right after we you know used our
sympathy card
and uh got a bunch of people to to
donate and we were
they just threw money at you we raised
over uh six figures in order to open up
that first spot
why didn't you tell me i would have
threw in a couple bucks he did he did
tell us how do you think we
were blasting that everywhere for like a
month
yeah he did a lot like i think we all
donated here
i actually thank you guys most of you
did yeah yeah
where were you i came to the studio
thanks man
did you pay at least to support them oh
okay they shot a video there
anyways so um i think opening that spot
up
was like still such a uh early
part of our entire journey and just the
idea of having a spot for us to come
just kick it yeah was the only intention
it wasn't like yo let's
build this corporation you know it was
like we got a spot
and even if we look at it now you know
that should look like a
souped-up garage like it doesn't but
sometimes that's the
best though it doesn't look really dope
the outside was wack
you can't help the outside yeah so i
mean i think that that was just like
planting the seed for what was possible
um
but really what it was what the actual
seed was not the building itself
it was uh the brand it was kendra's dojo
being able to actually call something
a spot and the the funny thing is like
having a
crowdfunding element to it meant that
before the spot even opened its doors
everybody already knew what kindest dojo
was we like performed a show on the show
yeah on abdc with the panels we called
that one kenji's dojo it's like welcome
to the kindest dojo
and then we crowdfunded for a spot that
was called the kindred dojo using a lot
of genius six
so suddenly everybody knew what the
kindest dojo was before we even signed
the lease on the spot
great branding dude i think that that
was a really really big thing for us to
do
um and then once we got the spot um
again it wasn't just about opening a
studio it was having a recognized brand
that was able to bring in other
interests from other people so when i i
was able to go out to china and partner
up
with our partners over there sign on
stage it wasn't just like hey i'm a
choreographer maybe i can come and teach
at your studios it was
hey i represent a brand that has
recognized you know me globally
and we do more than just have a
collection of artists who dance and
teach
we also sell clothing we have a studio
that people recognize where education is
an element
most of us are choreographers directors
and teachers that go abroad so like the
caliber of like what we have to offer
um transcends just like weekly classes
it's more like we can direct
programs we can organize competitions
judge things
there was a credibility that we had to
offer as a collective
and i think i took that to pitch to
different places versus just like
yo my name is anthony and i like dancing
i think the most important thing though
of what you said was
um that that like i don't think you
highlighted is the fact that
you crowdsourced which meant that you
created a [ __ ] massive community of
raving [ __ ] fans and that's
something that's really hard to do and
that's what got you to open up
the first brick and mortar which answers
their question
and the second one is more brick and
mortars no the second one is uh what are
the next steps for kenja's after closing
these brick and mortars now yeah i think
i i definitely want
china take them home i want to take a
moment to
for sure respect and acknowledge the
fact that it's been a really tough year
you know what i mean it's like um maybe
in the journey we
chose not to share on social media too
much like yo i'm super bummed out
because this is a really really tough
moment and like
you know we didn't have the means
necessary to continue this part of the
journey and blah blah like we don't
because they're going to be like shut up
my uncle died off a covet [ __ ]
right it's like stop being sad things
are tough but you don't really want to
complain because
you know at the end of the day you still
got your health you know for the time
being you know
um so just to take a moment to respect
that before really even understanding
the depth of like what it means to
move forward past that i think that um
it's a blessing in disguise right uh we
have yet to
truly understand the fruits of that
blessing but it's shifted a lot of our
mentality it's made us um
humbly speaking reflect reflect on the
last 10 years and like what we've done
what we've done to get there and also
what we've done to get back here
you know what i mean blame cove it all
we want but
at the end of the day where you are is
where you are and i think that that
beautiful ride has allowed us now
especially you know being in our 30s
having different focuses on life where
people are married wanting to have
children and stuff the priorities of
life have just
changed and the expectations and the
demands of it have just evolved you know
um so in terms of what's next i think we
still have a foundation of wanting to
support
uh all the kin you know with
sustainability with integrity to support
people so they can pursue their passions
and really be there regardless of what
that passion is whether it's dance
affiliated or not
but i think for kinjas we've gotten a
chance to recognize that the
the game has changed you know and i mean
the world is like
way more digital the world is you know
like it's harder to
get live events so much of our stuff was
based off of live
performances traveling and teaching live
competitions people coming into the
studio space
and relying on like people coming and
it's not to say that that's
yeah it's not to say that's not gonna
like be a prevalent part or come back
but the the digital world is
really like kind of the the new frontier
of like humanity
and so if i had it my way i would rather
wish we could all like
jump off the edge of a world and
suddenly the king just turned into like
digital beings and you never have to see
the real versions of us again and maybe
we can only go digital
ninja nft can you guys can you guys be
pandas i think that we're gonna be
can you guys be pandas variety of
animals oh okay oh i like that like kung
fu
like they'll be the praying mantis the
panda the stay
yeah everybody's signing ndas don't
don't talk about rabbit
these are these are exciting times
though you know what i mean and i think
um
it's it's easy enough to be like every
business needs to adapt
but i think there's also um an
excitement in the creative realms to try
and
always innovate and be ahead of the
franchise i think there's an exciting
space that we have yet to uncover
but i think it's because a lot of people
haven't discovered that yet and that's
that's part of the journey as a creative
are you guys going to build a
uh brick and mortar wuhan
first of all wuhan's probably thriving
way better than california it's a
beautiful [ __ ] positive perspective
[ __ ]
that i actually do want to highlight
like i think that's like what makes
any person successful at life in general
i think it's all perspective you know
what i mean like
regardless of the thick of the [ __ ] that
you're going through i think like having
that strong resilient mentality of being
like
yo this [ __ ] sucks but then going
like
but i think i'm gonna be cool or like
i'm excited to see what's next i think
that's what really
like that's what's dope i i wouldn't
really help with the whole wuhan
question though
is that is that gonna we're gonna open a
wuha one or no
ah i was gonna say that um i think one
of the biggest lessons that we got a
chance to learn especially as
you know kenji's is it's really really
easy for people to come together and
celebrate times that are like good
but having people stay together and kind
of
i guess celebrate times of vulnerability
um and rebuilding that's a
way different human experience that
really teaches you a lot about life and
yourself and your people and
i think that that was a huge blessing
that we got to still see like
everybody's stressed out and [ __ ] sucks
right now but like everybody's still
here
oh that's [ __ ] sick oh i love that
survivors
that's beautiful okay last question
last question this is the most important
question most important
so what's your favorite j kid member so
really think about it
really really think about it which
person from jk has the best chance of
joining kenja's
look at all of us i want to see your
judgy eyes question that came from them
anthony the people want to know
put your hat up who actually took your
class look at this look at this look at
this
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this oh
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] is this
i'm wearing your merch man i like this
move right here look at this guy
so good honestly at this particular
point of the game
best chance is probably does isaac count
hey i'm sorry i'm sorry okay okay i'm
sorry
no the question was from jk i mean would
isaac count as a jk yeah he's a jk
baby look at this he was he was acting
like whatever
you
honestly probably in this room it's it's
probably joe
it's probably a joke but also i also
think he's got the one with like less
ties to other people so it's like going
to be easier right you guys are [ __ ]
moving to vegas
look at this [ __ ]
yeah i thought you i called you a
brother man i got the most skills
well apparently you do i actually post
dance in my art online so do i
no you don't uh-huh i don't see any
dancing videos and there should be a
dance-off
i think there should be a dance off well
if you guys want to see it
let us know i'll battle you on instagram
yeah no
there'll be a battle on patreon what the
[ __ ] we're not on patreon
no i know this video isn't but they
wanna yeah you guys could see it on
patreon
patreon he's he's already in battle
though he's like
whatever dude yeah he already has his
[ __ ] he's already standing like this
youtube patreon whatever you want to do
is peter in first position i could let
you borrow my cobra oh you have black on
so it's cobra kai and
and then uh versus the karate kid team
mr miyagi dojo
[Music]
[Music]
you